um there was recently there was like you
guys had a uh you guys had an issue with
the security right that that happened
this is a few days ago maybe where they
had a guy who was a like it looked like
he was uh here we go armed man arrested
at RFK Junior campaign event in Los
Angeles was this guy armed and
supportive of you or was he armed and it
seemed like he was against you or was
there did you have any take on this
he was he showed up and he asked
um he uh he was wearing a U.S Marshal
badge you can see it in some of the he
was wearing a lanyard you can see the
lanyard around his neck there and at the
end at the end of that as a badge and
identified him as a U.S Marshal
and then he hit a federal ID on his belt
okay you can see there yeah right he has
some other kind of badge on his belt and
you see the badge around his neck and
um
and that was determined to be fake and
somebody from my Gavin Decker Associates
was just was doing is doing my security
they want you know the White House will
not give me a secret service protection
so I you know I've I've retained this
this group that's the premier
Security Group in the country and they
um and one of their guys looked at that
badge and said that's too shiny it's not
it's not a real badge and so then they
he why he called somebody else who's
armed
and the two of them cornered him and
then they called the police and they
kept him in the corner they didn't want
to grab them because they didn't want to
start a shootout
and they could see that he had shoulder
holsters on eBay and so then the police
came and arrested me he was asking for
me
oh he was looking for me and he uh he
had two shoulder holsters that were
fully loaded up pistols and then he had
you can see that badge on his hip yeah
he's badged up huh yeah and then he uh
and he had he was also had a backpack
that had another weapon in it
another like a sword he also had knives
on him and he had a lot of extra
magazines filled with ammunition so
he said afterwards apparently his
brother said oh he heard there was a job
opening for security but you don't go to
a job opening for security
guns and knives and two three pistols
his mother who brought him there also
was like you know like an Armory right
they had a whole car filled with with
weapons wow I have no idea I don't know
what he was looking for but I'll tell
you what the thing that you should do is
go on his YouTube I mean his uh Tick
Tock yeah he has a tick tock it's like
that he just opened so he only has one
really
yeah if you could find it nickel find it
it is uh
yeah it because
at the end of that thing he says
something to the effect of
I'm going out to do a job right now and
if I don't come back you know it's uh if
I don't come back report to your
commander
Donald J Trump
your commander-in-chief so it's a very
kind of okay you want to watch this it's
about a minute yeah it's worth watching
you gotta turn the sound up
oh [__] big homie Zorro over here I
think this is his brother talking to him
cause gangster [__] I hear you're the
man with the plan what's the word I got
it all
actually there's too much to tell you
right now
so I want you guys to go over to rumble
check out icons 2020
Sarge I will be speaking with him
and Alex Collier
you're not retiring homie you didn't
[__] ask me dog
I need you support okay assistant's not
doing well huh no yeah and this could be
also be an advertising for rumble first
name
[Laughter]
I would see him go to something like
this okay I think I've seen enough but
yeah I get it so this guy's like yeah
and he does this little you know kind of
let's see the end we can see this I
believe yeah sure the last
like I don't know 10 seconds here we go
if I don't make it back
call the [__] president your
commander-in-chief Donald J Trump
and where's he going I didn't see a door
over there when it was a wide shot so
that's the weird part if he's just
walking just over the like about some
tool chests wow I mean look dude just I
don't know yeah you don't have y'all
don't have the best track record with
like
um you know you mean the family yeah I
don't want to say that but yeah I mean
and yeah I shouldn't have said it like
that but you know it's like is it more
scary but you can't live in fear what
are you gonna do I'm not gonna live in a
fair yeah I I know yeah
it is what it is and
um you know but but the the White House
should definitely be giving me secret
service or can you save your receipts
and if you get in there can you get
reimbursed or not what no oh yeah oh so
and I think that's what they're up to
that they want to you know bleed me
white essentially you know from money
perspective but I'm
hey I'm the first candidate in history
that has requested Secret Service
protection they haven't given to but do
they give it to you this early because
here's what because the the Press has
been dishonest about this
you're entitled to it they have to give
it to you 120 days out from the before
the the general election if what what
circumstances to all candidates 120 days
out okay well you have to have a certain
polling number but I've I've surpassed
all the thresholds by far okay
so
um but like my Uncle Teddy was given a
secret service protection 551 days out
but he was also Apollo he was like a
lifelong politician well he was a he was
a politician but he wasn't even running
for president he
he was talking about running for
president against a president his own
party like me Carter but Carter said
you better protect him right away right
and even though he hadn't officially
declared the Secret Service protection
Obama got it 450 days out John McCain
got it
four or five hundred days out I'm I
think I'm like 300 days out now
Jesse Jackson got it Shirley Chisholm
you go down there's probably 30 of them
we've all gotten it long before the 120
days okay
and I get you know I mean we gave them a
68 page
um yeah I'm reading about that yeah and
why you should have it yeah
because I get death threats all the time
and I you know I had a mentally ill
person
I'm breaking to my house a month ago and
and make it to the second floor no are
you at your house yeah so oh my God you
know I mean so I I they should you would
think that the president would uh yeah
don't if you know Biden can't you just
like ask him well we're not I'm talking
terms at the moment okay
damn that's a bummer yeah because you
think you'd be able to hit him up and be
like Joey you know
trade you an ice cream for a couple of
front door goons you know you know what
I'm saying a couple Sharp Shooters dude
I bet you trade you sent him a box of
mint chocolate chip but he'll get
whatever you want you think yeah it
could be I mean you know I think every
man loves to have a dessert
um
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one